hello today we're going to look at what
you can do in your code
to make sure that it's not absolutely
chugging and ruining your frames and
making your games really slow so we're
going to look at
that way how you can kind of organize
and arrange your code
just some more broad concepts and
things that you probably should be doing
if you're not doing basically stuff that
makes games really annoying because i
don't know if you've ever played a lot
of the new modern games with high
graphics as you move into new areas and
stuff you'll notice that
you just you just freeze for like half a
second it's kind of frustrating and it
seems to be the way the game's built
doesn't seem to be anything to do with
your computer because
you'll even hear like streamers that are
just completely maxed out computers
playing like
player unknowns battlegrounds and
they'll just get huge frame pickups just
want to point out some things you can
look out for to make sure your games run
fast
alright so one of the main things one of
the first things that comes to mind here
is just
the stuff you're doing in the core main
loop of your game
because of course if you have a game
somewhere in there there's something
like
uh while running i'm just putting while
one here
and then you have all the stuff your
game does typically this will be like
update game state render and then
there's usually something that's like
checking but there's a lot of little
tricks here and a lot of things to watch
out for
most of the time this core while loop
will run
in a single thread when you're updating
this game state sometimes
you'll kind of get stuck on some really
long thing that it just chugs on
and it'll delay the render you'll end up
getting like
one two frames per second and it makes
the game unplayable basically if you're
getting
that load of frames what can we do do to
avoid
having a bunch of things pile up on this
game state all right so let's talk about
a few things here first of all you can
definitely async the tasks that be
delayed i'm pretty guilty of
basically hardly ever using this so this
is something i personally could improve
on is just
learning how to do this ac stuff a
little better next thing
you can do that i think is super
necessary is you can put things in a
queue
and basically process them one at a time
okay so if you have a cue
you basically pile things onto the back
of it and
process things from the front of it so
if you have a lot of things potentially
happening
all at the same time you can basically
make a whole cue of everything
and then process one thing per frame
rather than trying to do the
everything in in one frame and
potentially locking up your game
you can say hey just add it to the queue
of things that need to be done and you
can also even delay this further and say
hey we got a delayed cue
we process one of these every half
second these are the things that also
are not super critical to the immediate
response
although things usually in this queue
will feel like they're
immediately responsive because they
still end up happening pretty quick it's
just a way to make sure you're not
trying to do
everything all at once and locking up
your game on a thread so
yeah just make a cue of things that need
to be done and let the cue
be absorbed basically trying to think of
where i
originally kind of learned this and sure
i learned some in school
but also there is this book
called game programming patterns by
robert
nystrom and it's free there's an online
pdf version or web page or
is totally free i'll link it below you
can also buy the book off amazon if you
want the full physical thing that helps
support
mr robert who made this awesome book
this book is highly recommended if
you're a game developer
it just has so many little tips and
tricks and it does talk about this thing
i am talking about
i was feeling like i read this somewhere
i couldn't remember where so i went to
my bookshelf
and sure enough it is called the event
queue this is often used for
the ui or you know just interface stuff
that's not
super critical to the logic of the game
but it's really nice to know as soon as
you can
yeah you just put it in an event queue
having this book handy to
to read when you're bored or you know on
a trip or something is super awesome
i've pretty much read the whole thing
at this point it has definitely helped
me probably going to refer back to that
book a few times because it's got a lot
of this
kind of stuff about things to do or not
to do in games in general and patterns
you see
some of these patterns are kind of
automatically implemented or
will say they're implied so you're
probably already doing them and we don't
really need to talk about them
but the ones that are a little more
obscure or that you have to manually
calculate and program in we're
definitely going to try to talk about
so basically what you do is you make a
standard q
and this is a c plus plus thing and of
course there is a reference for it
i highly recommend cpp reference on it
basically a more
simplified version of a vector it's less
heavy than a vector
about as efficient as it gets and you
can only see the back or the front
so it's a it's like a line basically
which is
essentially what a cue means so as you
put stuff on here usually you want to
push back
and then you process whatever on the
front and you pop front
now also to use this you're going to
need some kind of event
class or something that in general
understands all the events of your game
which can be
you know that's kind of its own whole
topic and maybe we can talk about that
if you guys are interested
in seeing more about something like an
event class there's a lot of examples if
you look at people's game engines of
their event class and they can get
pretty complicated on their own but in
general it's just like
a list of all or a class that can handle
any of the things
that your engine could do and you put it
on this queue and then you process them
one at a time and slowly rather than
trying to
smash them all in one tiny frame update
and lock up your code so yeah
let's let's make a little demo of one
we're going to need to include a
queue of course i open this in visual
studio just to get a text file
uh so i haven't actually set this up as
a project this is totally example code
all right so we need an event class or
you could make this a struct or whatever
but eventually
essentially you want to be some kind of
event and you want this to be
like things you're i'm trying to think
of the best way to do this and it's
really hard
to like there's there's going to be
stuff like all the different keys you
could press all the different
ui things that could happen and stuff
like that
and you could also use some some
polymorphism or some
inheritance to to make this a little
more robust that gets really complicated
i don't really want to get into that
because then i'm going to start like
teaching c plus and this will be four
hours long so basically
it'll be like uh things you could
process
so essentially what you do is you just
make a queue of these events
and of course this would not be in your
main loop it would be somewhere else
and you have events and as you do stuff
maybe you press a key or something
happens in the game
and basically what you do is you add
things to this event loop so
yeah it could happen as part of this
update game state if like an
ai is doing something that causes an
event that needs to be triggered
or if someone takes damage or if you run
out of mana or whatever
something like that or if you press an
input button and it needs to do
something
that that could go on the queue that
could
all add to this cue so essentially what
you do
is once per update process it so it
would be like
uh events dot runt and then you would
process the thing so however it is
depending on what it is maybe you have a
function here that says like
process or something like that all right
so for now we're just going to put a
process
and so this would essentially do
whatever it needs to do
in theory and what you would do is just
once per update or once
per whenever you're ready to process an
event is you just take the front one you
process it and then after you process
you do a pop so it would remove it
because it's done no longer needs to do
anything you could could go even further
with this and you could have like a you
could store a boolean or a binary
that says whether it's done or not start
as false
and then you could also as part of this
process
say uh done equals true or something
like that
i'm not doing lines here just because
i'm being lazy
then you could have more logic in here
to say like if done
uh then remove it and if not so you
could get you know you could get pretty
you pretty crazy with this point
engineer however it needs to be
engineered for what you're doing in
particular
and also something that's sort of
related is
have a delayed update you could process
this cue as part of your delayed update
if you don't want them to happen too
much or if they tend to happen
too much or if some of them in general
happen to be seem to be too heavy to do
every frame
your normal game stay update or event
tick or
your game tick happens every single
frame so it could happen
60 times per second or 144 times per
second if
if your computer can handle that but
also you could have a delayed update so
you could have you could hold the time
so usually when i go to uh do this
timing thing i usually just grab
code instead of rethinking about the
whole thing of course i have it in my
little ancient archer engine here which
i work on
i have vlogs on that if you want to
check it out it's also on github core at
this point
somewhere in here there is okay yeah
here we go so in this
it's uh it's right here so i have my
while loop and
it has an update render pull events so
in my
update here is the stuff that keeps
track of the time
basically i would grab uh this code
and then we can use this elapsed time
which will update every frame
just some basic logic there to keep
track of the time of the game
so what we can do for example uh we
would just we would hold another
variable that says
like time so far static flow time so
far started out as nothing of course
and then every frame we go time so far
plus equals which one means we add to it
elapsed time
and then we would say if time so far
is greater than the timeout length
and that means enough time has passed
that we're good to go ahead and process
something
then maybe we want to do our event pop
or maybe you just have some certain
thing that only
checks every half second or something
like that so you can customize this sort
of thing
to save frames because this basically
means that rather than doing your whole
thing every frame
the only thing you're going to do is add
to the elapsed time
and then time so far of course once you
process an event
you want to time it out again so you
want to set this time so far
back to zero like so so once it
processes
make sure you reset this time otherwise
it's just going to start doing it every
frame
there's probably a ton more i could say
about this particular thing but it's a
general concept that can make your games
a lot faster and a lot more performant
to just
basically not do every single thing
every frame just delay some stuff
i guess i didn't really mention sound
before but i'll mention it now because a
lot of times
sound effects aren't critical to like
the logic of the game to
things hit points to know if it died
this frame or to know if it you know got
crowd controlled this frame or something
like that so you can often put
your sound effects on this event queue
and
process it when you get time because no
one's really going to know the
difference
if just a few milliseconds have passed
but if it becomes a problem you might
need to
rethink the design like if you uh i
don't know swing your sword
and you see the whole animation and then
after you're done swinging then you hear
the loose that's going to be awkward
but in general that's probably not going
to happen because you're going to be
like
only a tiny bit through the swing and
then you're going to start hearing the
whoosh and it'll sound fine you don't
necessarily need to play the sound the
exact moment you hit the hotkey
hmm you know that really is the biggest
thing just controlling
the flow of how things are working so
that doesn't get overloaded and lock up
your frames
now there's some other stuff but it's
kind of less critical like
you don't want to load the same textures
over and over and the same models in the
same vertices
so a lot of that can be controlled by
basically just carefully analyzing
things but
in reality and i think for the most part
as far as
loading things it's usually a one-time
thing so it's not quite as important as
the runtime unless you're loading and
unloading
during runtime which you want to be
careful about one thing that kind of
annoys me personally in games is when
they put your character into the game
and then they start loading stuff
so that like you see like the skybox and
nothing else for like minutes or
something
i always feel like you should have some
sort of loading screen while all that's
going on
you can always like improve your asset
loading a tiny bit
but in general it's not necessarily
going to affect your runtime a lot
unless it's something major so
it's usually kind of an afterthought i
think this
should give you some ideas how you can
improve the speed of your game and
your code and make sure you're not doing
anything too terribly
slow that's going to ruin it for your
players so let me know if you have
questions let me know if you have more
tips down below
i'll be reading them and responding and
maybe we'll do a part two if a bunch of
stuff comes up
alright thank you goodbye
[Music]
you